a few guys up to a car
and i thought
one of them hooked me in the head they
were amateurs
if it was me as i've just
done whatever i'm in for my younger days
so anyway i've went flying in the lake
come on you're supposed to be a gangster
when i'm sitting my legs i try to cut my
throat down my face
as you can see i've got a scar and i
walked along my mother's street laughing
because i never got my neck
[Music]
so tell me what was your childhood like
well my childhood was a i came to a
working class family
i was the oldest day
five i'd had four three brothers and a
sister but my oldest brother died when
he was 18 months
we moved through a place in springdale
up to a place called black hill in
glasgow
and it's not just one of the deprived
areas in the glasgow it's one of it was
one of the most deprived areas in this
europe
this was the way back in 1966
67 i was only six at the age of fourteen
uh
my dad and mum used to always have lots
of fights and all that police were at
the door
blah blah blah blah and eventually my
mom had enough that was that my dad was
out
and uh
to tell you the truth my dad was a
strict
disciplinarian
and we were scared to hang about with
the boys at the corner so as soon as he
disappeared we run at the corner and
within a year me gary and alan were on
approved schools
for stealing cars shoplifting
and then i got bosto at 16.
gary 18 8 years for slashing the guy's
thrower
and then
it was just a life i cried for me
we used to just steal cars
and when the jeweler shops were opened
just draw right outside them and they
slide shaming them and take the money
and as as the years went on the the
offending just get more serious
what was it like going to prison at such
a young age oh it was shocking it was
short see the approved school
i could just about handle that see
boston
boston was so much
tough and the prison officers are very
violent so as well
and most of the prison officers are
exxon because
boston detention center way back was
supposed to be a deterrent
and
you got really if you bend them on and
you make your bed the bed block
you're doing floors with toothbrushes
and
as supposedly they tell you but it never
deterred me
i'm only 18 and then there's guys for
your liverpool scent i mean
call me jock you know that but many
years later i would find that that was a
nickname for us and say who you calling
y'all he says you call me joke once me
admit i says i'll do you
so he called me again
and then at the time he only radios
there was any tvs in that then this is
78.79
and then i put a pp9 battery in a sock
and he was lying his business he still
might call me job and i smashed him
early he'd do it
but these uh
22
was i got the gun market
and i started uh
robbing post office people
and they had security guards
my friend was on the run phase shots and
he came up to see me while he was still
on the run
and he presented me says
would you like to win in this robbery
us as much as ellie says i suppose with
six million pounds i'll hold in bank for
from the
the holy
davinci
area
and he says uh
you don't need to get into the banking
you can be the driver
no
i don't need to get in the bank
now i can trust you
you'll be there
so i just went in there was no luck
there was no alarms at the time when on
the floors of the main bank and the vote
was at the back
it was about 15 16a staff
the guy
had the key is that at the back there's
a treasury grill gate there's a big gate
you opened then with that so there's two
gates that scroll the treasury you'll
get
so by this time when the bank staff was
lying down in good run
money was the key that
the manager
his name is brian thomas i still
remember his name after all this time
he was saying in the work
and he says just let me go and open the
door
he says come in and everything says
don't let anybody stand for
my friends they get sick everybody they
were passing the paths from going oh
he's at the key she's like
so the gun just blasted into the ceiling
and then a plaster came down and on the
head
but
the story
since then
very organic scottish press they keep
saying somebody's a girl was shot in the
head
but it's just as bad to tell you the
truth because it was traumatized and i
told you i apologize to her anyway
she's not known person non-present so
she she survived oh [ __ ] no it shouldn't
it was never serious i wonder that but i
could imagine that mental state after
that i mean
and after it all went wrong police came
but you managed to escape i managed to
escape from the caravan site and uh
i knew the police were looking for me it
was a scottish crime squad then they're
called the
serious crime squad so i arranged to
meet a sheila in a chinese restaurant
and you saw for five weeks
and then and i said did you get followed
she's like don't be selena
so again a woman came in
and i says right away
by the way i said undercover copper she
went over there you're starting again
you know i says well would you eat sweat
i says i'm on the run
it's not for something silly
she went there they're a nice couple
and there was four guys sitting in the
chinese restaurant oh he's passed his
driving lesson so i'm starting to relax
but see the couple come in i noticed it
was what once it gets you weeks later
they just did this silver pen
facing your table and i think it was a
micro
microphone after about two hours
we saw these people coming in but they
were on civilian clothes at this place
and then and i'm going is that any of my
enemies and i'm getting my horn in my
pocket my gun
and then before you not see the lovely
couple
they were the first two jumped and
talked to me see the four or five people
your driving licence they were all
police
so you then got sentenced
i got 16 years at the old bailey
and then for the gun i told you in the
chinese russian that was after i got two
and a half years for that
so my fault was 18 and a half years
i get a
first five years in prison in top
security prisons i was a cat
was a
i couldn't handle it i i just couldn't
handle it that i mean
okay because i had such a big sense i
kept saying when's this black tunnel
going in
and then
then after about six years
my mother and sister came up to see me
i mean that's me say it within me and
they went time as well
and then
but see it
be very honest with you
see my first
year second year first year
i kept saying to myself please god i'll
never get into trouble again my life
but she's the years working on seven
eight years now years i've gone
well what am i gonna get you and i'd say
anybody it's no it's no glamorous
there's a lot there's a lot of lonely
light spent in there
if there's one sort of worst experience
that you had in there what would that be
well i found two guys that hanged
herself
a prison that kind of affected me
because i knew them that way
and uh
but there was lots of that that that was
the worst but there was lots of
incidents not i mean
what's the instance because i was
category for nearly nine years
and uh
i was in all these top security prisons
where
other the the irish
ira
brinksma italian gangsters everybody you
may feel all over the world that i mean
and there was another guy next door in
the actual holy butler
he killed six people no i mean there was
people that i call in ireland
who killed five gay people and all that
i met him
but i'll tell you a funny story when i
was the night before it was getting
released
in november 2001
and i'd been dying for years to go get
out of prison i was walking up and down
my sail
and i went i don't really want to get
out
and
i've said to myself
i've got to get to the same life i had
i still wanted to live a fancy lifestyle
uh when am i going to get the money for
a house car
blah blah blah
have i got to get back to this again
because i had no life skills i never get
taught twitter
in prison
and then
i i was i was shocked at myself when i
was thinking that what went up and done
myself but then i did get out so i've
done 10 years
five months
five weeks
five days and five things
and then
i never went to you see people these
days a day three four years they got you
open presents in the community i just
get through that door there was no no
even a day out to see my mother so i was
kind of a very bad i have to tell you
the truth that i never had
rehabilitation and things like that you
came out or you did this party
strathclyde police
made an intelligence report put you back
in
because it was april fools the urgent
system would say well i'm not feeling
about i'm getting straight back into
serious crime
i've done something serious to somebody
who i won't name
they were called the new kids in the
block
when i went to prison and i came out
they were i wasn't in it fairly
and i could make 40. so they were fair
through them with the new
kids in the block and i had to run in
one night they tried to keep me
before i was an old man
uh
i'd done something
and
they've connected to heavy families and
they're all millionaires now
and uh
for a year
i was getting told to everybody
i was a dead man walking
i just kept saying everybody i'll be the
last man standing
but during that year
i had a couple of flats on that the
police gave me 70 the osmonds now the
death to
life one that's where they come and see
you
and then you say your life's in danger
and i just go
nothing away harm me are fighting me
since uh i got that 16 years at little
bailey
may 2009 i had this mercedes and i said
i had a blink blink registration
plate on it
i think i was 47 then
and then
there was a bomb found under the car it
was a viable device by the way
the first one with an officer took half
the building down
but the bomb squad and all that came
they evacuated 16 houses
so
that was the friday
it was friday the 9th for me
2009
and uh
then four days
later the tuesday
a few guys jumped to a car
and i thought
one of them put me in the head they were
amateurs
if it was me either just
done whatever i meant for my younger
days
so anyway i've went flying and the light
come on you're supposed to be a gangster
and uh
and i think therefore i had some
phenomenas
but i i never had any maps because i was
drinking with the bomb police are going
to be watching me and all that because
it was big news at a time up there
and then
then the rogers brought knives up but it
was just in the corner from my mother's
house i've never ran away in my life i
was 47 48
and then
and i could have only run 200 yards and
then i never i started trying to read
them but they got me ironically in a
church gate
at my mother's house
when i'm sitting my legs i try to cut my
throat they've done my face
as you can see i've got a scar it's
called a mars bar in glasgow
and that's me quite vain but that scar
doesn't bother me but they tell you
truth the scar was very bad i had to get
through
plastic surgery it was hanging off and i
walked along my mother's street laughing
because it never got my neck
so what was the turning point how did
this warfare resolve itself the turning
point basically was some people came and
said me because i was all out for
revenge
and he says look
it's one each
sort of a one each
everybody's willing to let it go because
it was coming scoot my mother and then
that was that then i i wrote a book two
years later
i never named a minute i just called
them the new kids in the block
and then
and just for them
my life kind of
went normal
i became an ex-criminal and
that was that
you're 60 now this is all behind you
what's next what's in the future for you
i'll just take everything day by day
it would be it would be great to have
some money and all that
but it's not the bo the end all
everything the thing is
i'm glad i'm still alive i didn't expect
to see 50 or 60.
so every day is a bonus
i said tomorrow i'll sit at 7 o'clock in
the morning go and get kennedy that was
my sign off shotgun it was named after
president kennedy i said i want one
chamber one buck shot filled with rock
salt
and the other one with the normal bug
shot and all right yeah i'm not messing
about with these people they're
dangerous i'm going to shoot